hello in this video we will discuss how
to enhance your learning experience on
Khan Academy as you work through
assignments and lessons first ensure
you're logged in to your Khan Academy
account by checking that your name is in
the upper right hand corner
logging into your account is important
to view your assignments and earn
progress towards your classes
on the left hand side you'll find your
classes where your teacher has assigned
Mastery goals or assignments for you
click on the assignments tab to access
the assignments from your teacher
now let's review the top five things you
need to know about how to complete
assignments on Khan Academy
first let's discuss the types of
assignments there are two main types of
assignments on Khan Academy
the first is practice indicated by the
Mastery icon
practice can include exercises quizzes
or unit tests
while completing assignments you will
receive instant feedback after each
question you answer
the second type is instruction noted by
the play symbol and the paper symbol
instructional content can come in the
form of videos or articles
helping you learn new skills or review
Concepts that were covered in class
all videos have subtitles for easy
following if you're stuck Take a Hint
feeling stuck when learning is natural
but don't get discouraged Khan Academy
offers hints for specific questions
providing step-by-step guidance
be sure to jot down those hints for
future reference
Additionally you can watch related
videos or read articles to gain deeper
understanding
you will find help related links under
the skill you are working on
if needed don't hesitate to seek support
from classmates teachers or family
members
be patient and persistent don't worry if
you're not satisfied with your initial
score on a practice exercise
you can always retry assignments until
you achieve a score you're proud of
just click try again to start over
you can even go back to assignments with
past due dates to improve your score
remember every Challenge and mistake is
a part of your Learning Journey and
contributes to your intellectual growth
check your progress stay on top of your
Learning Journey by selecting progress
under my account on the left hand side
here you can review all of your
activities on Khan Academy including
completed exercises watched videos and
read articles
depending on your learning goals you can
filter to view specific content or
activities
for each completed practice you can see
your current Mastery level the number of
correct answers and the time spent on
the activity
regularly checking your progress helps
you stay on track to meet your goals
make Khan Academy your own customize
your Khan Academy experience to suit
your unique learning style rewind or
slow down a video as needed to ensure
that you can understand the concept
Khan Academy is available in over 50
different languages so you can learn in
the language you're most comfortable
with
easily switch languages in your settings
if you prefer complete assignments on
your smartphone by downloading the Khan
Academy app on Android or iOS
remember the sky's the limit for your
Learning Journey Embrace challenges
learn from your mistakes and never
hesitate to ask for help when needed
with Khan Academy there's no limit to
what you can achieve happy learning
foreign
[Music]